According to American Psychiatric Association, and the new DSM-5 criteria, to
be diagnosed with major depressive disorder one must have a depressed mood, or
loss of interest, or pleasure in daily activities for at least. Two consecutive
weeks. Now remember that this mood must represent a change from the person's
baseline, that is, it has to be different from the way the person usually acts.
They must meet at least five of nine specific symptoms associated with major
depression. Almost everyday for at least two weeks. A depressed, or sad, or
listless mood, that stays low all day for several days. A reduced interest or
pleasure in doing anything. A significant change in body weight, that could be
either an increase or decrease in body weight. Sleep disturbances, sluggishness
or restlessness, daily fatigue or loss of energy, daily feelings of
worthlessness, self-reproach or excessive guilt. Lack of ability to concentrate
or think clearly, recurrent thoughts of death or suicidal ideation. Now most
importantly, these symptoms must significantly effect daily functioning, in
terms of both social and work related contexts, and also be a source of
distress. Notice that there's a wide variety of symptoms and a person must
experience at least five of these symptoms to be diagnosed with major
depression. However, it's up to your doctor to diagnose you with major
depression. So if you experience any of these symptoms, and are concerned about
it, you should consult your doctor or counselor. Check out the PDF we put in
the instructor's notes box. If you're interested in finding a therapist, this
document can help you. Now you can see how these symptoms differ from our
occasional sad or blue moods. This is a lot different than being rejected by
someone, or doing poorly on an exam, or realizing you gained a few pounds last
year, and the sad moods that can accompany those events. This can be different
than being rejected by someone or doing poorly on an exam, or realizing you
gained 15 pounds last year. These can be disappointing and produce negative
moods, but as far as debilitating symptoms of major depressive disorder, they
just don't cut it.